well good morning everyone welcome to
the grain storage webinar on hygiene and
structural cleaners my name's Chris
Warwick I'm a consultant based in
Horsham Victoria and I manage the Jerry
Caesar own storage extension project now
my role in this project has developed
over the past 10 years and since the
very save loss of Peter brought up last
year and their service the GAC is
southern region we've grown storing
workshops and information such as this
as I mentioned the quick housekeeping
the Q&A window allows you guys to ask
questions already just click on the Q&A
to open a window type your question in
the box and then click send if you'd
like to send an anonymous question you
can select send anonymously if you don't
want to be identified and please feel
free to ask questions as we go
you might have already come with a few
questions so feel free to put those in
straightaway or as you think of them the
way that adds them as we go or at the
end
by all means top those questions I'd
like to think the base AJ for
facilitating this session for us today
appreciate their support and providing
these workshops for us if you have any
trouble hearing me or can't see the
PowerPoint presentation please let me
know and by that question box well let's
get into it
on-farm storage hygiene and structural
treatments
you know just as an overview to help us
figure out where hydrogen and structural
treatments fits into the bigger picture
of manging on-farm storage it's really
the first step so if we look at in the
whole system
we're really about trying to prevent
pests prevent the infestation of pests
prevent the damage but they're great if
we don't get that right and we still
have to do a pest control then we're
looking at phosphine or on-farm pest
control or a commercial fumigated and
then lastly we also want to consider
grain quality so imagine moisture
temperature but in the pest prevention
side of things
hygiene is structural treatments along
with aeration cooling protectants and
monitoring there about pest prevention
so that's what we're going to talk about
today best prevention trying to start
clean and start with a good fresh
storage with no pest contamination to
the research to kick things off with
this is some research done by the
post-harvest research team up in
Queensland through the department okay
this is to give you a bit of an idea of
how quickly growing straight pest can
breed up so we've got months along the
bottom so you can see my mouse so you
can see after three months this is in a
one-ton bulk bag after three months that
boggle they've just left in the shed
we've reached nearly 5,000 beetles after
six months the numbers really spiked up
- so you can see that those few maybe
half bag for all bits are growing that's
long around throughout the year often
left there for longer than six months we
get it you know really good
understanding of how quickly they become
a breeding ground
so that's part of Hygiene is to use to
be able to - the other Queen those
bits of growing up as well not just in
in the solos themselves but around the
sheds and very decline around the place
something else that some who have
recently found again for a bit more
research some aside note actually to
some research was someone asked the
question will for every adult insect
because that's what we're seeing that's
what we're monitoring you is the adult
stage of the life cycle
how many adolescent insects if you like
how many egg larvae pupae can we
actually expect for every one adult and
the research found that for every adult
you can find in Grain expect eighty to
ninety egg larvae pupae so it's easy to
see how numbers build up quite quickly
so that's what look at prevention is
better than cure up we really don't want
to get to the point where we find
insects because as we've just seen
they'll breed up really quickly and I
came to me and to what the research
shows is really about preventing an
unwelcome environment for pests and what
we know is that they like primarily they
really like shelter they like to be
sheltered from the extreme conditions of
the enemy so they don't like getting
really cold or that like you really hot
so somewhere they can shelter from the
heat and from the cool and then secondly
they need a bit of food so anywhere that
you can think of solos are the obvious
spot nice and sheltered a little bit of
food left in there other things around
the brand the farms like your seed silos
or the choc feed or machinery that's in
the shed that might have a little bit of
grain residue left in it all those
places that are really good harvest for
insects even consider hoppers and things
left around the silos that might be
overturned so they don't fill up with
water but actually create a nice little
shelter and if there's a bit of grain
left on the ground that they're covering
up then there's shelter and food all the
sudden so consider those places as
insects happens as well even hay and
grass around the side that can provide a
bit of shelter see the team
that sort of stuff lying around silos
can provide a finish every one but
that's the hygiene a lot of things the
second one we've done hi Jen we've won a
look at structural treatments so that's
about killing any insects that may be
left after we've done the cleanup
let's of the fire Jane first so as I
said hygiene is not just limited in in
the solos but if we look at the picture
on the top left here we've got a bit of
grain left you know in a hopper
underneath Asolo really quite a nice
training ground there for insects to to
start bringing away and quickly infested
me into silos the bottom left there
we've got in the back of the truck
and remember equipment anything you
clean up make sure all the trucks chaser
bins other bins trailers and all those
sorts of things that the grain go
through I really cleaned up well we're
looking at silos even consider the
design of the silo and they've had that
the solar sits on the scene silos on a
concrete ring rather than a concrete pad
it really it makes them a bit hard to
clean if we use a nice smooth concrete
pad it that really does make hide them a
lot easier to sweep that growing up when
we're looking at spill crane around
silos people often get it quite panicky
about spilled grain around silos to be
honest grain that's the spill thinly
across the ground sort of one grain thin
doesn't provide enough shelter for
insects to live that well grain piled up
if you've left a pile of grain this
other side that provide enough shelter
for insects to live so just consider
that when you're doing your claim again
headers are really common spot on
insects in the top right and picture
there we've got some trench aeration in
a big flat one silo something that we
often see
is particularly input of silos now come
in with the full floor aeration systems
false wall perforated floor aeration the
issue with those sorts of setups we find
is that they're they're impossible to
clean under so after a few years will be
a bit of dust residue be the grain
residue fall through that floor and
again create a perfect Arbor for insects
to breed under that floor come along and
put hub fresh harvest grain in and in as
soon as you put it in the insects are
investing so that trench aeration for
aeration cooling trench aeration is is
quite adequate and in the real advantage
is that it's easy to lift up and clean
out so again when you're looking at new
silos whether it be flat bottom or cone
bottom look how easy they are to clean
any spots that grain can get stuck with
we're looking at types of cleaning
obviously the broom and compressed air
and water for the comb bottom silos is a
good idea to dispose of that waste grain
so not leaving it in a bucket or really
been beside the the silos or in a pile
we actually want to get rid of that
grain so come on various benefits and
the livestock many peopre live at some
here even spread it out thinly across
the ground south of germany machinery
similar research just to try and
highlight it goes up in Queensland again
did some research for us and and asked
how was contractor who considered that
he'd clean he's had a fairly well at the
end of the season they said can we catch
the first 40 litres of grain that goes
through the header at the start of the
next season we said wait so they went
along with the bucket and collected the
first 40 litres of grain that went
through the header and actually stopped
counting when they found a thousand less
of grain bore in that first 40 ratings
so that's a head that was thought to be
reasonably clean but they hadn't used
dry side you know haven't used a
diatomaceous earth product so
again encourage you what you think might
be clean is still an insect harbor if we
don't use a structural treatment or look
what Tommy you shall be clean up again
we look to research to tell us these
answers we rely very heavily on research
finds and what it finds is that insects
will breed and travel when when the
temperatures warm up so you can see in
june/july there where the temperature is
cold insect reproduction is slowed right
down insects don't tend to move around
as much so that's the best time to do
our grains drug hygiene so even this
time we were in August now before the
temperatures really start to warm up in
the spring good time to do our hygiene
clean them up get rid of them before I
start breathing and moving around the
Flies
so that's how a gene structural
treatments where we're trying to do is
structural treatments the main one that
we would suggest people look at is a
diatomaceous earth so that's a naturally
occurring product at the mine product
not chemical based it's actually if you
put it under a microscope it's actually
it's very abrasive shaped and it
actually scratches the waxy cuticle on
the insect and they end up dehydrating
so it's a physical mode of action so the
insects can't develop resistance to it
that's why we like the product and
therefore is effective on all the main
grain storage pests so that's what we're
trying to do is clean the storage app
create an unwelcome environment and then
we're really trying to kill any insects
that may be left there often get asked
about other products people think look
similar like lime again the testing
that's being done shows that lime was
really not effective we did we need a
diagnosis earth product something like a
dry side we're looking at how much we
actually need it's really not much take
example of a hundred and twelve tons
silo we only need about 420 grams I'm
not talking about feed volumes here for
something like a harvester we might need
a couple of kilos through the harvester
in the front not not large volumes we're
not performing a heap of the people just
happening just enough to really light
dusty
shall we do it I'll reply de
diatomaceous earth for solids comb
bottom solos a little blowback gun you
can see here so we opened the top lid of
the solo open the bottom lid we measure
out now our quantity of diatomaceous
earth in the bucket or something similar
and then using the air compressor and
the venturi gun the blowback gun we blow
it up through the solo and you'll
quickly hear the clatter - see you like
in the right hand picture once you've
measured quantity in step back have a
look and the dust and start floating at
the top of the solo when you see that
start to happen shut they'll be closed
the bottom manhole other people I've
seen and heard used leaf blowers and
most sorts of things and to get the dry
side or diatomaceous earth dust in the
silo anything like that would be
effective while we're trying to do
within an even coating around the solid
walls the roof even in face it can be
applied as a slurry which is
particularly good for sheds concrete up
the walls and ceilings in the shed next
work it is pretty hard on pumps so be
aware of that if you want more
information I'm Adam I'm certain
definitely hopefully they do consider
personal protective equipment I'd asked
mask and some gloves and certain goals
as I say bracing so it's a nasty in the
eyes make sure we do there goes the
other warning on put out there as I said
it's not chemical based
they product to use I would hate for
people to run into trouble though store
impulses or oil seeds if they happen to
get a bit of this diatomaceous earth
settling in the cone of the silo and
then you've got a bit of discoloring on
possible seed I hate that two different
great to buy the grain so my suggestion
there is to to you to do the hygiene do
the structural treatment do automations
birth and then just before harvest if
you cannot store part of the royal
scenes just give that's all I couldn't
sell just to make sure there's no no no
quantities of do that it compiled
somewhere that that might be in your
sample few key points on on diatomaceous
earth takes about five to 10 days to
ticular insects but to thank you for the
in the six to twelve month range so
again that's why we suggest can be
applied in the abstinence
yes as near as 10 days before harvest
but really the better is that he's
became message there can we apply
there's a dust or a slurry it's most
effective in the dry environment so
under 65 don't know what it means so
think about inside your solos is
relatively dry inside your equipment
machine the shedding begin is relatively
dry it's not chemical based no pest
resistance which is a really good thing
main structural treatment as I just said
I crack them into green silos just
before storing all sated parcels for
that added extra security to make sure
we don't get downgraded on those those
high value commodities and again make
sure we wear gloves dust masks in and
actually gold so I need to add to that
just a warning it is registered product
it can be added to grind it 7-eleven
actually edit to grind that used to be
thing these days we see more and more
grain buyers actually prefer that it's
not used in that way it really does
change the flow of the grain we're
talking about cereals only here of
course so we actually don't recommend it
the other two remain there's other
suggestions I hear people say what if
you add a little bit to the first bit of
grain that goes in the silo and add a
bit to the last bit of grain that goes
in the solid form bit of a cap or a
barrier in theory yes good theory
happens in practices we can expect will
be some insects in that grain box
somewhere and if we've got a barrier on
the top and the bottom we're not only
trying to stop Intex from coming into
that grain but all stops also stopping
is a giving me out so we might go and
have a look at the grain in storage at
any point and say long walks clean or
counseling so a teeny insects even seem
a bit of grain from the top but what
could be happening is insect bringing
down in the middle of that grain stack
they're just not coming to the surface
because of the DA so actually wouldn't
recommend that of the practice or the
risk that they could be insect activity
in the middle of the grain stack in the
middle of a silo and we can't see it at
the top of the bottom because of the DEA
effect key points to run through again
clean up during the cooler months so
this time of year is well worth doing
actually including machinery in the
cleanup dispose of that waste ground and
then follow up with an application of
structural treatment to the Plains
Georgia so that's that's why doing those
structural treatments it's really quite
quick and simple if there's nothing too
complex to it which I really like
anything that's simple and also
cost-effective I think is a good thing
so it doesn't have to be complicated
common sense but really does make a big
difference
starting with our grain storage Queen
gives us our best chance for a group as
well so I'll ask a minute in a minute
for you guys to certainly use that
question and answer window type your
questions in
now and I'm sure there'll be some
questions if you've got to come with or
a bit amorous part
what are you doing that I'll just
reiterate if the people would like more
information stored grain comm that are
you the website you can go to you can
contact us we're going strong extension
team on info at store grain con blame
you or you can call the hotline at any
stage 1-800 level and that will put you
in contact with your closest grain
storage specialist
well you're typing the questions another
amount of that the next webinar will be
on the 10th of September same time 10:00
a.m. and we're going to have a look at
upgrades to existing storage that one
also keep an eye out for an email that
will be sent to you shortly
we just put a a second survey in there
to get some feedback on this webinar and
check if you guys have been very aware
of them and what we can do to improve
them so we've got any questions any
question that would like to ask happy to
take those now if you want to type them
in the question and it's a window
just while you're thinking of your
questions there one of the ones I often
get asked at workshops is can we use a
product like diatomaceous earth around
the silos so around the base of the silo
what we can as we said in the previous
couple slides there it works best in
here is the dry under 65% meaning so for
those areas around the silos we were
actually bit off to use a spray on
product something like a for nitrile
thorn as a structural treatment is good
for the grass and gravel or concrete
areas around the silos we can actually
use very sort of products as a
structural treatment purpose in K the
diatomaceous earth the inside the store
these needs are dimension
can say any questions coming here I
think those questions you guys if we ask
them by all means if you if you do think
of something later
please refer that call that hotline
1-800 weeble and that will come straight
through your huge grain storage
specialist certainly consult with store
grain calmly new website there is a fact
sheet on there on hygiene and structural
treatments which includes most of the
content that we've just been through
there's no further questions thank you
again for joining us and thank you to
the BCG for hosting we look forward to
catching up with you again on the 10th
of September for a webinar on upgrading
existing storage thanks again